une politique de confinement assortie
d'une répression que je trouve moins
personnellement quasiment obscène
infliger des amendes de qui vont jusqu'à
3500 euros à des gens qui qui qui gagne
qui sont peut-être au rsa et qui empoche
plus qu'ils sont en train de devenir
dingue dans le confinement et qui vont
essayer de prendre l'air d'accord une
telle violence une telle férocité
jusqu'à des peines de prison ferme et
c'est alors que dans le même temps on
oblige d'aller au travail que les photos
du métro parisien gare du nord à 6
heures du matin montrent des quais
bondés montre des gens à touche-touche
d'accord qu'est ce qu'il raconte ce
gouvernement qu'est ce qui nous dit il
oblige les gens à aller travailler à
paris à 14 millions d'habitants dans un
métro bondé mais il fait surveiller les
plages du finistère par des hélicoptères
dans des excuses mais il a marqué
liberté du conte sur mon front enfin je
veux dire
cc c'est quoi le truc tu liras qu'elle à
quel moment jusqu'à combien de temps va
se de notre gueule avec ce truc
là je veux dire ce soit il ya un
problème de confinement et on confine
soit on peut envoyer tout le monde bosse
et dans le métro et faut arrêter
d'emmerder le monde parce qu'ils vont
prendre l'air sur une plage donc ce que
ce que ce qui me met la puce à l'oreille
c'est là je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est l'âme
la violence de cette répression la
férocité de cette répression sur des
histoires de promenade
ça ça ne va pas le coup de l'hélicoptère
et je trouve extrêmement symptomatique
fâche venir c'est celle là encore vous
avez un test en grandeur nature qui est
un test de l'obéissance de la police est
ce que la police va les cent soixante
mille personnes mobilisées est-ce qu'ils
vont accepter cette cette politique de
répression
c'est un test est ce qu'on va trouver un
gendarme assez avec suffisamment de
neurones dans la tête pour conduire un
hélicoptère au dessus d'une plage pour
traquer une petite vieille qui va
respirer oui manifestement le trou donc
il ya un vrai test en grandeur nature de
contrôle d'une population avec une
répression plus rentable mais qui
s'adresse sur du plaisir de la détente
d'accord mais pas le travail le travail
faut aller bosser par contre eur par
contre se détendent ça c'est pas bien ça
c'est là vous avez une moralisation du
problème
enfin c'est insensé
[Musique]